- [Instructor] We've
already done multiple videos
on the crusades but what
we're going to focus on
in this video is how the
crusades help catalyze
the start of what many historians consider
to be the first international
financial institution
and that is the Knights Templar.
So let's just make sure we have
a good hold on the context.
So over here we have our timeline.
It's occurring during
the high middle ages.
In other videos we saw
the first crusades start
at the end of the 11th
century, started really
by Pope Urban the second
with the purported reason
to help the Byzantines take land
from the Muslims,
especially the Holy Land.
The first crusade is for
the most part successful
but they don't return that
land to the Byzantines.
They set up what are
known as Crusader States
or Crusader Kingdoms including
the Kingdom of Jerusalem
and just to read this
timeline that I drew up here,
green shows a time period when at least
Jerusalem is controlled by the Muslims.
Red shows when Jerusalem is controlled
by Western European powers or by these
Crusader Kingdoms which were
essentially Western European.
These red parts on our timeline show
when the actual crusades occurred.
So you see the first crusade
causes the change of control
of Jerusalem from the Muslims to
the Western European Christians
and once Jerusalem was under their control
and it would continue to
be under their control
for roughly 90 years, you could imagine
that many pilgrims from
Europe went to the holy sites
in the Holy Land especially in Jerusalem,
but this was not an easy journey.
Not only was it a long
journey, these are the paths
that I showed in previous
videos that the crusaders took,
but this could also be the paths
that many of the pilgrims
took in order to go to
the Holy Land and you
could imagine a journey
of this distance going
through multiple kingdoms
in this time period could
be incredibly dangerous
and many of the pilgrims
actually were robbed
or sometimes worse on
their way to the Holy Land.
So in 1119 a small group of Knights
led by Hughes de Payens,
they go to King Baldwin the
second, King of Jerusalem.
Remember they set up this crusader state,
the Kingdom of Jerusalem headquartered
on the temple mount and these
knights tell King Baldwin
the second and Warmund,
or Patriarch Warmund
the Patriarch of Jerusalem, they say
we would like to protect these pilgrims
on their way to Jerusalem.
These guys think it is a good idea
and so in 1120 they give them some space,
a headquarters on the temple mount
in order to start their group.
If you translate the Latin
version of their name
it translates to Poor
Fellow-Soldiers of Christ
and the Temple of Solomon.
Now the reason why it says
and the Temple of Solomon
is because they were
headquartered on the temple mount
and the Al-Aqsa Mosque is believed by many
to be on the site of the
original Temple of Solomon,
but this is often shortened
to the Knights Templar.
This is their symbol, two
knights riding on a horse
to show their poverty, but
they don't stay poor for long.
They are shortly thereafter
recognized by the Pope
and many people start
donating money to this order.
Many more people volunteer
to be Knights Templar
and so over the remainder of the crusades
they become an important
institution in Medieval Europe.
Now most folks often
associate the Knights Templar
with being Knights.
You can see here one of
the Knights on horseback.
Here you see the Knights
protecting pilgrims
on their way to Jerusalem
and they did do that.
They did protect the pilgrims
and they were also active
in battle during the crusades thereafter,
but it turns out that even
though on the peak there were
on the order of 20,000 Knights Templar,
only about 10% of them
were actual soldiers,
were actually these warrior monks
as they're sometimes called.
The rest of the Templars
created this fairly significant
complex infrastructure
to do multiple things
to support the goal of the Knights Templar
and perhaps most
significantly they developed
a sprawling financial
enterprise of the time.
If you were in London and
you wanted to do a pilgrimage
to the Holy Land you would need resources
in order to do that and you
would want to have access
to your wealth once you got to Jerusalem
and so you could imagine
if you were traveling
over a long journey to
take gold coins with you,
not only would they be heavy
but more importantly
it would be dangerous.
A lot of people might want
to take that gold from you
and so one of the services
that the Knights Templar
developed was that you
could go to their temple
in London essentially deposit your money,
they'll give you a note
of credit saying that,
we the Knights owe you a
certain amount of money,
and then you make your journey
and when you get to Jerusalem
you can give that note
to the Knights there and they
will give you your money.
Now this is something that
we take for granted today.
I can go to an ATM machine
anywhere in the world
and for the most part I
can put in my ATM card
and get access to money, but there's a lot
of infrastructure that makes that happen.
Today we have telecommunications,
we have satellites
that help information go back and forth,
we have servers that keep
track of all of that data.
They didn't have that in the middle ages
and so you can imagine this
is a very powerful idea
that I could deposit money one place
and then I could withdraw
it someplace else
and we still don't fully understand
how the knights were
able to pull this off.
It requires a lot of trust
and how were they able
to authenticate the notes of
credit at any of these points?
Not only did they do this type of deposit
and withdrawal in multiple locations,
they also because they
had all of these deposits
and people were also
donating money to them
just to support their cause,
they were able to provide loans.
Often times loans to very powerful
individuals like kings and nobility.
They were often brokers
in major transactions.
This is the reason why
historians really do consider
them perhaps the first
true international bank.
In other videos we talk
about how in 1187 Saladin
is able to retake Jerusalem
but then in the Sixth Crusade
and the Barons' Crusades it
goes back to Christian hands
but then 1244 it's retaken
again by the Muslims
and it stays under Muslim
control all the way
until the end of World War One
and so with Jerusalem taken
in 1244 the whole goal
of the Knights Templar, the whole purpose
of their existence starts
to become less important.
Although at this point
they are a significant
and influential financial institution.
As we go to the end of the 13th century
the whole crusader mentality
starts to lose steam.
You have the Eighth and Ninth Crusades
but they aren't successful
and as we get into the early
14th century you have this
character Philip the Fourth,
King of France and he has
incurred a lot of debt
in order to have wars
especially with England
and a good bit of this financing
comes from the Knights Templar.
He is a powerful man looking for solutions
to his debt situation and
he realizes one solution
is maybe just to arrest the people
who you owe money to and then not only
do you not owe any money to them,
but you can seize their assets
and Philip the fourth does exactly that.
Famously on a Friday the 13th in 1307
he arrests many Knights Templars
including the Grand Master,
the leader of the Knights
Templar, Jacques de Molay.
He tortures them.
They eventually confess
to a whole bunch of things
but then they retract that confession
and they're not willing
to retract the retraction
and so in 1314
Jacques de Molay as well as
other Knights Templar,
especially in the leadership,
who do not agree to those
confessions are burned
at the stake in Paris
and this is considered
the end of the Knights Templar
although there are many legends of how
they have continued on perhaps in secrecy.
So the Knights Templar are to this day
are a subject of fascination.
There's many legends associated with them,
but one of their biggest
historical contributions
that isn't often talked
about but we know happened,
is that they really laid
the foundation for what
we today consider modern
international banking.